hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen today i wanted to do
another little vlog um just because i
got this little vlogging camera i'm
gonna do more of these things i'm having
lunch so um just gonna eat my
my take out whole foods salad here my
massive sound uh so we'll see how i do
but one of the things i want to talk
about because i got asked a lot about
this this week was about my journey to
become a registered dietitian so i
thought i would share with you how i
became a registered dietitian
and also in the description i'll share
some resources if you are thinking about
going down this path okay so first of
all let's talk take it back like forever
ago i was a student um in high school i
went to an actual an art school
and um i was hardcore and artsy fartsy i
did musical theater um dance singing
um
music
art
all the things i was really into
performance arts that was my forte so i
stopped doing any grade 11 and grade 12
biology and chemistry because i was so
busy doing dancing and musical theater
and singing and blah blah
and so i really was not interested in
doing anything science related i had i
basically made it made it my mandate
that i would never go into a career um
that was science related so i just
didn't follow i didn't kind of follow
through on the rest of those courses and
then i went to university i was doing a
ba a basic general ba
my plan was to go to teachers college to
teach theater and music and so i was
going down that path and part of my
degree required us to take a science
course some kind of um like a human
sciences course and i chose anatomy
and
i loved it i mean total it was like a
early 20s
crisis if that's a thing i'm pretty sure
it's got to be a thing because those
were hard years um and i came to this
realization where like i felt like i
didn't even know who i was anymore my
identity had completely changed and so
i i felt like you know my whole life i
was so like right-brained i had never
even exercised my left brain before i
never thought about numbers i didn't
want the black and white i was living in
the gray i was living super creatively
and imaginatively um and that was where
i was comfortable with because also my
family and my parents are also very arts
focused um people so my whole family
were very kind of focused in the arts
so this is what i grew up with
nobody was into this into the sciences
that's for sure
and
basically i had this realization like i
actually really like this
so i transferred into kinesiology
and
just like it was bringing me joy the
numbers were bringing me joy the the
black and white was bringing me joy
i was loving kind of all of the
information about the body and it makes
sense because at the same time i was
really at the height of struggling with
my eating disorder orthorexia if you
haven't watched my whole video about
that you can check it out right here
but in that moment i was really
interested in health and as i went
through the kinesiology program it
clicked to me that
you know what it's maybe not the
exercise portion that i'm really
passionate about which is largely what
kin is about it's more than nutrition
related parts which made sense because i
while i was going through kind of my
eating disorder recovery i was seeing a
dietitian so i had some insight into
what a dietitian does um and obviously i
was still kind of struggling so i was
obsessed with food and i was thinking
about nutrition and food and my idea of
healthy food even though it was largely
just like [ __ ]
read out of like a people magazine
anyways
um i decided that it made more sense for
me to transfer into a dietetics program
now side note i'm going to leave some
information below but not all nutrition
undergraduate programs are
accredited and will lead you down the
path to becoming a registered dietitian
there's also a huge difference between a
holistic nutritionist or a nutritionist
and a dietitian and i will have to do a
whole other video on that because that
warrants
it's gonna there's a lot of ground to
cover on there but long story short um i
did the research i found an accredited
nutrition program but there was one
thing standing in my way and that is
that i didn't do the grade 11 and grade
12 biology and chemistry so i had to go
back while i was a student at um in
kinesiology and pick up these courses in
kind of like a continuing education
program
it was a lot um i had to have a tutor
she had to walk walk me through it it
was so overwhelming as someone who had
never thought in that kind of science
mind before to have to literally
re-learn how to think
um but anyways i graduated from grade 11
and grade 12 biology and chemistry i got
into the nutrition nutrition program
and while most accredited nutrition
programs are four years my i only need
to do three years because i had the
transfer credits from my previous degree
which was great eating bread
i can't just sit and brought food not
eat it
i'm gonna try to be polite
okay
probably gonna spin my teeth now but
whatever so
basically um in my nutrition degree we
covered everything from food science
biochemistry chemistry biology
physiology exercise or not really
exercise but like nutrition
pathophysiology nutrition for different
kinds of disease states um nutrition
through the life cycle
social and cultural dimensions of food
um social dimensions of food all of
those kinds of things and or social
determinants of food is what a food
social determinants of health
quite a broad curriculum which is really
important um and so i did in three years
graduated top of my class and when i say
top of my class i mean like actually top
top in my class i graduated with a 4.32
average at a 4.33 i had all a pluses
across the board except for one
a
minus
and lady if you are watching right now
you know who it is you know who gave me
that a minus and i'm still pissed about
it anyways so that was kind of like
as far as i'm concerned as much as of a
miserable experience of as my undergrad
was that was the easy part next we had
to get an internship it's not just
enough to do an accredited undergrad
program you either need to do
a one-year internship or you can do a
master's program that combines an
internship with a master's degree which
usually takes about two years or so
sometimes more
i've also heard that and well here in
canada and saskatchewan they now have an
undergrad program which is combined so
you not only get your undergrad but also
do the practical experiences of the
internship program which is absolutely
amazing i don't know why they're not all
doing that because let's be real
it is so
unfair in my opinion to have this
bottleneck of students who have done
their undergrad who are
a plus students who are crazy amazing
students
and they can't get these internships
because everybody's amazing
on top of being an amazing academic
student you also have to do all this
volunteer work which is crazy you spend
hours all your weekends and evenings are
spent doing volunteer work working both
paid and largely unpaid jobs that are in
the field to get experience and put that
on your resume also for me i was the
president of the nutrition student
council
so yeah i had the leadership i had the
volunteer work i had the academics all
going for me and the way it works is
that you applied to these internships
and then you'd get matched i've heard
that this matching system doesn't happen
anymore and that it's each each
university or program is completely
individual on its own
don't quote me on that that might have
changed however it's still a bottleneck
and is still largely very competitive so
it's it's really not surprising to me
that nutrition students have such high
levels of like type a personalities and
stress and anxiety and ultimately also
eating disorders there's actually
evidence of that as well higher
correlation of of eating disorders in
nutrition students
lots lots to unpack there yeah so i
applied to the internship
and i didn't get it i did my interviews
i included all the places i applied for
and the first round of of those
internship letters went out and i didn't
get one it was literally the most
heartbreaking day of my life i mean
really isn't in retrospect i've had way
worse days trust me hashtag infertility
but um i will say it was really really
hard and basically you go to school that
day and nobody makes eye contact with
you nobody wants to talk to one another
because you know you don't want to ask
you don't want to you don't want to
upset someone's feelings you don't want
to brag you don't it's overwhelming it's
a toxic environment and then two days
later once people have had a chance to
kind of apply um you know reject or
accept their offers a new round of
internship offers went out and i
thankfully got one of those and so i did
an internship
it was one year it was a grueling year
it was emotionally hard physically hard
long days um just so stressful the
pressure is unreal
thankfully some of my best friends today
i found and i i got an internship um and
that's because we really had to stick
together and and form a bond and we had
to kind of
help each other through some of those
difficult days and difficult times um
and i graduated wasn't a dietitian yet
then i had to write an exam that feels
like six hour long exam which you paid
to write and then you have to pay a
bunch of fees to your college and then
you can use the term register registered
dietitian
so
there's a reason why us dietitians are
so
protective over our title and that is
because we've we really have had to go
jump through hoops to get there
um so
can i take an eating break do you mind
you can fast forward to it
all the edamame and good things the
cheese and the nuts
they're all in the bottom i don't want
to eat the lettuce
so
after all that i graduated as a shell of
my of a person
and i was kind of like feeling so
resentful and just miserable in the
dietetics field in general that i kind
of wanted nothing to do with counseling
i definitely didn't want to work in the
hospital i i think the internship made
that very very clear to me
but this was not the the route um that i
wanted to go down um and i was kind of
hobby blogging at the time while i was
going through my undergrad and
internship really just doing recipes on
my like a little food blog
um doing restaurant reviews not
nutrition related i just wanted to talk
about food and considering i had that
4.332
in school basically everyone and their
grandmother convinced me that i needed
to pursue academia i needed to go all
the way and so that's what i figured i
was supposed to do i was destined to do
i um got a full scholarship to a very
prestigious sociology program a master's
that rolled into a phd
and my goal as a dietitian was to
research kind of some of the social
aspects of eating and a lot of the stuff
that i talk about here in the channel it
just happened was this is really just my
area of interest so um it made sense
that i kind of approached that from an
academic perspective as well
however if i thought that the undergrad
sucked and the internship sucked my
master's really was depressing
basically while i wanted to do research
on the sociology of food which is still
fascinating to me obviously
i had to go through all this like you
know the the basic um
kind of con concepts of sociology that i
had never learned anything about because
i did not have a sociology undergrad
so i was reading karl marx like one page
at a time again and again and again
being like what the f is this i don't
understand
anything i'm reading right now and it it
does not interest me at all so i was
very miserable um and so i had a
presentation on like a monday or
something like that it was all ready i
had written it spent all week working on
it and that night i had this epiphany
where i was like i am so miserable
i'm not going to be happy doing this not
for the rest of the year and definitely
not through a phd you got to really love
what you're doing to do a phd
i just really wanted to get my blog off
the ground and and kind of work
full-time doing this blogging thing
which at the time was not a real job
like nobody was a full-time blogger that
was not a career option but what i did
was i pulled up my computer
and i wrote a document that was called
abby's dreams and i wrote down
all the things that i wanted to
accomplish in the next year one or
foreseeable few years write a cookbook
get on daytime tv expand my blog to you
know a bunch of viewers all over the
world and i'm really happy to say that
i've done all of those things on my
to-do list many times over in fact other
than just one one book so far
um and i took a leap i took a full leap
i emailed my professor i said i'm not
coming in tomorrow i'm gonna speak to
the dean i'm gonna have to pay back my
entire scholarship i realized that which
sucked
but it was so worth it because it felt
so freeing
and at the same time that i was breaking
free of this kind of like expectation on
me that i was supposed to be some
academic superstar i was also kind of
shedding my disordered eating
my blog really did kind of serve as the
jumping off point to a healthier
relationship with food and i explained a
lot more about that in detail in my book
the mindful glow cookbook so if you
don't have that definitely get the book
it is in the description below um i talk
a lot about that
so i took a huge leap a huge leap of
faith that i had no idea what i was
going to do or how i was going to do it
but i i did and the reason why this path
made sense for me as a dietitian was
because i had a background in theater
and tv and performance and all that
public speaking etc so it was a real
natural progression for me i had i
basically created a whole new niche a
whole kind of area of practice
that was definitely not something that
we were taught about in school when i
was studying to become a dietitian there
was no there really was no media classes
that were even touching on any social
media components now i believe that they
do
thank god but um back then
not so much so knowing that i think a
lot of you guys well not a lo i don't
know if a lot but i i get a lot of
questions from my viewers about my path
to become a dietitian or saying that you
are an rd2b or a nutrition student
you're thinking about going into
nutrition i want to offer a little bit
of advice on you know helping you
through this process both the undergrad
and also the internship too because you
really can't become a dietitian without
going through this whole pathway so
number one is to start volunteering now
i know
it's hard but really put your heart into
it because you want to make sure that
you explore a wide range of different
dietetics
[Music]
areas of practice so clinical and
research um public health counseling um
kind of food service there's so many
different places that dietitians work we
don't just all wear lab coat lab coats
and prescribe diets or hand out candace
food guide or america's food guide in
the hospital i don't actually know
anybody who's a dietitian that just
hands out canada's food guide just so
you know
but anyways yeah there's just so much to
explore and you really want to just dive
in and dig deep and that will really
give you a good indication too if this
is something that you actually are
passionate about because let me tell you
if you get through the if you're in the
undergrad and you're being like oh you
know what maybe i don't actually really
like this don't put yourself through the
hell of an internship or a career down
the road if it's really not feeling like
a good fit so this is a good opportunity
for you to learn the ropes and also very
important for your your resume for for
you to get those internships number two
know your why
so when you do those internship
interviews it's really important that
you stand out because every single
student i'm telling you
looks amazing we have amazing grades
we're all type a we study hard we work
hard we volunteer hard we we have so
much leadership skills it's it's
incredible um so you need to stand up
and know your story know your why you're
passionate about this industry why you
have longevity here
and i think that's really does really
will help you stand out amongst the
crowd number three
network go to lots of events go to
conferences go to expos put yourself out
there meet people talk to people get to
know what the other dietitians or kind
of industry leaders are doing um i think
that really does make a difference
because when you go to your internship
interview and maybe you've already met
that person hey you've already got a leg
up okay number four learn some good
study skills i cannot tell you how many
people just do not know how to study and
i think it's such a really a really
important skill
um because studying like you're going to
be doing a lot of it i'm telling you
there's a lot to memorize and sometimes
i think too much to memorize like no
dietitian ever has had to tell a patient
or client about the krebs cycle don't
know why we had to memorize that but
anyways um yeah you're gonna have to
memorize and learn a lot of things so
figure out your learning style um it
might be worth taking a little course
about this at your local university or
college or even there's lots of
resources online or on youtube
to help you learn some really good
learning and kind of note-taking and
studying skills number five find a
mentor someone that you really look up
to someone that you can shadow and learn
from and really kind of
watch how they interact in this industry
i think
really will kind of set the tone for
your career path i had an amazing mentor
her name is jackie jean graz and she
taught me about hey she taught me about
intuitive eating i probably would never
be the dietitian that i am today if it
was not for her so
find your jackie i guess you could say
um and uh and you know take the time to
really invest in learning with them
next i don't remember what number we're
at but i would say
um you know ask for help if you are
struggling because this is a very
overwhelming process it's super
stressful it's anxiety provoking
reach out a lot of schools universities
and colleges have
counselors and and people that can help
you
kind of walk you through this process i
definitely think it's really worth
taking the time to um to kind of just
get help i know we think i don't have
time in the day to go to counseling it
will save you time uh because you'll be
way more efficient and you'll be a
happier healthier person and on that
note take care of yourself you know make
sure that you're nourishing your body
with good food exercise move your body
focus on good sleep and stress
management and take some time to be
social to have those kind of fun nights
with your girlfriends or or your
classmates um you know it is a really
stressful kind of program i i found and
i think everybody finds that it's super
competitive um so find your people find
the people that you really truly trust
and those people very
very well likely will be in your life
forever because you have been through
absolute hell together
uh yeah so on that note i guess i really
sold it but i would say um of course i
love my job i love my career i'm so so
grateful to be a dietician and i think
this industry is just blossoming it's so
exciting right now um and i obviously
made a very kind of unique uh niche for
myself which you can do too find your
niche find what you're passionate about
if you're a dietitian student or an
intern and you're looking for volunteer
opportunities i take a lot of interns so
definitely leave me a comment below and
i'll let you know how to get in touch
with me so guys again hope you enjoyed
this video if you did be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
with any questions you have about the
industry about me i'll do lots more of
these kind of q and a's um if you have
any kind of questions i think super fun
and casual let me know if you like this
kind of style vlogging video um it's
definitely more casual than a lot of my
other videos but good to switch it up
and uh subscribe to the channel and i
will see you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]
you